[Music]
welcome everyone I'm Alexander Rose I'm
the executive director here at the long
now foundation and you are at the second
of our shelter-in-place seminars about
long-term thinking from our normal
series tonight we have a special guest
from SETI Lawrence Doyle and he's gonna
be speaking about a kind of a technology
that is one of our oldest technologies
and we I think we often take language
and communication tools for granted but
they are technologies of a sort that
have allowed us to connect with our past
and our present and even the future with
certain types of written and other
communication tools and it is seem
obvious for a very long time I think to
to all of us and obviously to
researchers more recently that animals
have been communicating with each other
but it's only with some of the newest
tools that were being they were able now
to understand the extent of that
communication and these are the same
tools that people like Lawrence Doyle
are now applying to signals that we have
been listening to for a very long time
from the cosmos and to understand is
this signal or is this noise and and if
we don't understand the language just
like we don't understand much of the
language from the animal community how
are we going to determine a signal from
a noise and so this is why SETI has
turned to animal communication
specialists and researchers like
Lawrence Doyle to start to understand
this and he's going to share a bit from
the cutting edge of this space with us
today welcome Lawrence Doyle thanks very
much
I want to acknowledge my colleagues
Brendan McGowan and Jim Crutchfield at
UC Davis and also Fred sharp at the
Alaska well foundation and Michelle
fournaye at Cornell we're a
collaborative group and I'm the SETI
expert my background
astrophysics but also information theory
and it's information theory that we'll
talk about today as the mathematical
tool with which to try and derive an
intelligence filter for the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence so the
basic idea of this talk is that if you
can for example use antarctica as a
proxy for Mars to study conditions for
possible life on Mars and you can also
use humpback whales for example as a
proxy for receiving an extraterrestrial
intelligent signal so that'll be the
theme of the talk it's mixing SETI with
animal communication and in particular
bottlenose dolphins and humpback whales
so at the SETI Institute we we have our
president retired dr. Frank Drake and
many years ago 60 years ago he basically
came up with an equation for organizing
one's thinking about extraterrestrial
intelligence and these are the factors
that go into that do you have a good
star do that do those stars have planets
and given planets is there an ecosystem
in other words liquid water is what we
use for proxy right now and given a
place to live does life develop does
biology happen and of the biological
species do some become intelligent
enough to have a complex communication
system and the reason that's highlighted
is that's going to be the focus of our
talk today although anybody at SETI
Institute is allowed to go up and down
the Drake Equation finally F sub C is do
intelligent species develop interstellar
communicating technology and then lastly
L which is we're most ignorant about and
that is how long do such civilizations
last while you we can study Egypt but
that only lasted their civilization
lasted only 3,000 years so that's the
Drake Equation and in that context is
the reason that an astrophysicist is up
in Alaska every
courting humpback whales now we can look
at factors like good stars and a good
star may explode but that in itself as
we can see this is the spiral galaxy m96
41 million years ago a supernova went
off there and supernova create the
chemicals every chemical but hydrogen
and helium which was made in the Big
Bang were made in supernovae or merging
neutron stars so here we see a supernova
at the 12 o'clock position on the
picture on the right excuse me and that
is basically a dandelion of the galaxy
it's created the elements with which
trees and people and humpback whales and
and planets are made of and it also
basically transmits them throughout the
galaxy well another skip is to the term
F sub P and that great progress has been
made recently on that in the last 15
years with a launch of the Kepler
mission Kepler discovered over 4,000
planets including some of Earth's size
and you can see the planets in the upper
right there in the Kepler field of view
so I'll just say I was on the Kepler
science team my job was to find the
first planets
if planets could exist around double
stars since half the stars in the galaxy
or double it would be as significant
find if we found that not only do double
stars have planets but that they could
exist in the habitable zone so I was
fortunate to spot this guy and it's a
small red star and a solar like star and
it circled by Kepler 16b and because in
Star Wars Luke Skywalker was on a planet
called Tatooine that had
we'll star sunset I thought it would be
fun to nickname it Tatooine and one of
the guys from the NASA team manager
called George Lucas and asked if we can
nickname this system Tatooine so could
he come to the NASA press conference so
he had a press conference and George
Lucas couldn't make it but his the
director of Industrial Light and Magic
John Knoll showed up so we got to have
him as part of the the press conference
and it turned a scientific discovery
into kind of a world-class news story
Tatooine discovered science fiction
becomes science and so on so that was a
lot of fun I wouldn't want to live that
way but it was a lot of fun for about a
week here's a movie of the system a
simulation that's Kepler 16b there which
by the way is in the habitable zone of
these two stars which changes as the
stars orbit each other so it moves you
know in from the inner to the outer part
of the habitable zone these two stars
are called eclipsing binaries because
they go in front of each other and the
planet was discovered because it
transited in front of both stars so that
was a neat discovery and so we now know
that circumbinary plants exist and
almost half of them are in the habitable
zone so there may be some mechanism
putting planets in the habitable zone of
circumbinary planets in the habitable
zone around their two stars there may be
a mechanism because that's about four
times more frequent then we find planets
in general in the habitable zone okay so
this is a general background of where
I'm coming from before I started doing
intelligent signals from the oceans of
Earth and you could call that
extraterrestrial if you want to
substitute aquatic for terrestrial so we
can practice remote detection of other
species by looking at the millions of
communication systems both biological
and botanical on
earth and we can derive general rules
mathematical algorithms derived from
information theory to develop a
mechanism to look at intelligence that
whether there's intelligence in the
signal and the signal itself I mean the
way SETI has been performed so far as to
ask the question is there a transmitter
out there and you can make narrow
transmissions one Hertz wide in other
words you can tune on to a radio channel
and turn the dial and you're on a new
channel well nature can't do that the
narrowest I think it's an O H maser in a
gas cloud emits radio but you'd have to
turn the dial 311 looking for narrow
carrier waves but they have not examined
the message because how could you tell
from the message if it was intelligent
or not well I think I can convince you
by the end of this talk that we've come
up with some beginning methodologies to
quantify whether a message itself is
intelligent so in some sense SETI itself
search for extraterrestrial technology
is what's been going on but the search
for extraterrestrial intelligence is
just beginning
finally the rules can help SETI by
broadening the detection parameters in
other words by looking at all different
kinds of communication systems on earth
we hope to derive mathematical
representations that generalize what
intelligence is because so far frankly
we've been looking for human-like
intelligence and there are discussions
at SETI meetings as to whether they're
transmitted PI or the golden ratio or
some mathematical thing but the minute
you're face to face with a humpback
whale you realize that they're
intelligent incredibly intelligent but
not human so we have two deep provincial
eyes our thinking about what an
intelligent signal is I think before we
can maybe recognize an alien signal
if and when now to make sure we're not
confusing an alien intelligence with
something like astrophysics we started
our art analysis with pulsars pulsars
are regularly pulsing supernova remnants
but at the time of their discovery they
weren't known to be well they were
called L GM's which stand for little
green men and the basic idea was that
they're so organized I wonder if it's
emit a measure of technology so here's
what a pulsar sounds like you can think
to yourself is this intelligent signal
Morse code what
so if you heard that would you say
that's a technological beacon of an
intelligent message well we will examine
I'll show you in a minute
some of the intelligence filter
mechanisms that we apply and we applied
it to pulsars and you'll find that will
have no difficulty distinguishing
astrophysics from a true
extraterrestrial intelligent signal
meanwhile these are some of the species
that we've looked at bees dance that's
their form of communication cotton
plants basically talk to well I'll look
at that in a minute but they basically
send chemical signals orcas humpback
whales bottlenose dolphins all use audio
and chimpanzees use facials and gestures
as well as audio and elephants use
rumbles in addition to trumpeting and so
on so in other words all animals
communicate and all plants do as well
and it'd be a shame to not practice on
them right we'll look at bees just for a
minute
bees of course start out as nurses and
all the bees you see flying around are
females and then they graduate to
construction workers and then they
finally graduate to navigators they go
out and find honey and report back in
the hive and the way they report back is
they use what's this image shows the
waggle dance and the waggle dance they
have muscles in their necks that
indicate where vertical is in the dark
hive and they waggle at an angle from
the vertical to where the honey source
is and the vertical means where the Sun
is and the angle of that waggle looks
like it's tilted right now about 30 40
degrees that's the angle from the Sun to
the honey source the number of curves or
waggles is the distance so they use
polar coordinates in other words and the
time it takes to go across that waggle
before they make the loop that's going
to be
how much the winds blowing so they have
to they get an idea of how much honey to
tank up on so they can make it there and
back the the young bees that are new to
the waggle dance have to watch it
several times but the older established
bees they watch one waggle they go right
to the honey source so it looks like
it's a learned behavior what's most
interesting is that it is definitely
symbolic the honey and the flower is not
there in the hive so they are discussing
something that isn't present and there
was some argument in the literature
whether bees have symbolic language but
I think it's now settled the bottom left
shows a swarm and there it's called the
DV a V dance it's a different dialect
you might say of the bees and they're
the the scouts are discussing which has
which scout has found the best hive so
it's a kind of democracy there's a nice
book Cornell professor wrote I believe
called it's called honeybee democracy so
we have a democracy that's millions of
years older than ours
so in general I think people that study
animals and plants for that matter have
found that every that the critter
they're studying is more intelligent
than they thought when they started I
don't know any instance where they
researchers said gosh they're dumber
than I thought it never goes that way
this is an from a paper I wrote about a
communication system analyzed with
information theory between a cotton
plant and a wasp so the idea here was
that if we can apply in not just an
inner species or inner phylum but an
inner kingdom from the plant to the
animal kingdom information transmission
then we could apply it to
extraterrestrial signals someday if and
when we receive one
so basically his cotton plant is sending
a one-way air traffic control message to
this wasp
and the wasp what did pretty well but 73
percent success rate on landing on the
right cotton plants the cotton plants
had predators some were worms will say
and the other was a caterpillar and so
they put a gas chromatograph in the
cotton field and they took all the
Predators away herbivores and all the
dead leaves so there's only a chemical
indication as to what plants the wasp
which likes the caterpillars should land
on and that it should not land on the
worm-infested
cotton plants and sure enough about 73
percent of the time the wasp would land
on the the caterpillar infested cotton
plants so that means I would say that
this air traffic control system is
evolutionarily young because it hasn't
reached peak efficiency also the cotton
plant was putting out 2.4 bits of
information which means there are five
choices so that was the plants
vocabulary and I speculated in the paper
that there for the cotton plant why
would have a vocabulary of five if it
only had two predators so I said there
were more predators predicted there were
more predators and that's what the
botanists that called me from University
of Pennsylvania they had found that they
said how did you know there were no more
predators and I said well the cotton
plant told me and that's when I think
botany people got interested in
information theory which could give you
an insight that you wouldn't ordinarily
have even between the plant and animal
kingdom but we're gonna emphasize in
this talk and in our research we've
emphasized marine mammals because they
put most of their communication in audio
which we can record they also are social
they're social networks are very complex
they have culturally passed on traits
and we know they're highly intelligent
so so we'll emphasize bottlenose
dolphins in humpback whales this is a
bottlenose dolphin dictionary it's a
made up of contour k-means cluster
analysis 60 points for those
mathematicians at this talk and we used
it to classify the whistles by contour
which we also did an experiment there
was experiments done that showed that
vamanos dolphins
consider contour to classify the
different signal types so in other words
the contour is important to them kind of
like us saying howdy or howdy or howdy
the frequency shift and the duration
doesn't doesn't define what the word is
the words defined by the contour howdy
so similar with bottlenose dolphins so
now we're going to skip to the first
intelligence filter we would use and
it's called sis law and basically Ziff
had some graduate students that he had
classify actually number count the
number of e's the letter E in Ulysses
count the number of ours count the
number of o's and so on down to the
number of Q's and then plot them and
space by the way in English occurred
about 15% of the time about 10% of the
letters were e about 8.5% or T and so on
about 0.1% were cute so that was that
was interesting because he did a plot
and the plot itself produced a slope of
45 degrees or minus one now what did he
plot he plotted the frequency of
occurrence with ease at the top
and queues at the bottom and he just put
them in order and he had a line fit and
it made this minus one 45-degree slope I
know it doesn't look like 45 degrees but
it is so what does that mean that means
that there's a distribution of the
letters in a book in English that has
this -1 slope which means that the most
frequently occurring compared to the
next most frequently occurring and so on
will produce a logarithmic -1 slope so
he's like well that's amusing but then
he did Chinese letters minus 1 same
thing then he did Russian phonemes minus
1 hmm that's interesting if you record a
Japanese conversation it'll come out to
obeys IFS law if you plot the phonemes
in order of the most frequent to the
least frequent well that's interesting
so basically most almost all human
languages obeys this law and there's a
lot of other codes that you can use this
law to decode like for example Morse
code does not obey this law if you just
plot a dot and a dash but if you plot a
dot and a dot and a dash and a dash and
a dot in a - and then - and a dot plus
dot and dash so that you have six
components it goes up the slope goes up
and by the time you are including dot
dot dot and dash dash dash as individual
unique signaling units it's obeying this
law so in other words you can use this
law to decode so let me just point out
that we did a pulsar we looked at those
Pulsar pulses I showed earlier and we
did as if plot and y equals minus zero
point six nine six three that's the
slope so in other words a pulsar has as
if slope of minus point seven so isn't
that interesting it doesn't obey this
law which is great we wouldn't have
expected a pulsar to obey this law and
therefore be a possible linguistic
signal
some of you out there that are familiar
with this law you may think that there
are other things beside languages that
obey this law and that's true but this
law is a necessary although not
sufficient condition to be a language so
in other words if you fiddle with the
units of signaling and you don't get
this law then you don't have a language
you can go to something else so it's a
first line test if you do get zips law
you may have a language but you're going
to have to apply a further analysis a
deeper intelligence filter that is
called Shannon enterpise let me just go
back here okay now this is unpack well
Sam is this a language
[Applause]
okay did you just hear an intelligent
communication system well it's hard to
tell isn't it unless you use some
objective mathematical feature if we
look at the frequency of occurrence of
all human languages we get a minus one
slope and it wasn't thought that any
other communication system on earth
would have this minus one slope as a
matter of fact linguists regularly
talked about zips law being a
distinguishing factor in human languages
compared to all other animals well you
know after a hundred years of saying
that human physiology was entirely
different from all other animals which
is a Victorian notion we finally outgrew
that we even found that genetically the
simplest plant is more complex than
human genetics but right now we're still
in this should call it a transitional
period where we're learning that human
language may not be that isolated
compared to you know all the other
critters on earth so I think this law
and what I'm going to tell you about
information theory will help so
information theory basically measures
the dependence of signals on each other
so it's called entropic order and the
first level of entropic order zero order
entropy is just what is your vocabulary
and what we do is we take the logarithm
base 2 of the number of signals and what
that means is just how many bits can
your language carry from just it's for
example its letters so the second order
entropy while the first order entropy is
this law basically the second order
entropy says what is the diagram
structure of a language so in other
words it says
given a letter I'm thinking of a letter
guess what the letter is you might guess
e but what if I say it's the second
letter in a word the first letter is a T
well now you're probably going to guess
e or H well you wouldn't have guessed H
before but knowing that a T precedes
this letter you see that there's a
conditional probability in other words
the T affects what follows it and so you
guess H and that would be correct
because the is the most common written
word in English so information theory
basically is a measure of the complexity
between signals and their conditional
probabilities and that one way of
thinking of it is somebody asks you what
is information theory well it measures
the relationship between signals so you
might say the rule structure so given a
certain rule structure
why would I mean humans use rule
structure but why would animals develop
it and it turns out bullet to hear it
allows error recovery in other words if
you get back to your desk and you've
made a copy of something and it's a bad
copy then you can fill in missing words
and missing letters because there are
rules so you're using the context which
in other words in mathematics is the
conditional probability between the
signaling units in this case letters to
recover missing letters that's a
perfectly legitimate thing to do so is
there some reason to do this in the wild
well yes if signaling is important then
this allows error recovery so anything
that allows error recovery of a critical
signal has survival value and this
example of low toner which we all have
seen and you can actually get missing
letters and words
and recover them okay pulsars do not
have a cyst law good well they were baby
dolphins that were let me first preface
this by saying human babbling does not
obey this law human babies babble with a
more equal frequency so it's a much
flatter slope than -1 but as they grow
up the the yellow dots in this show that
they they're random and then the yellow
developmental stage is when and when
babies get very redundant they say the
same thing over and over mama mama mama
or whatever and they're encouraged to
drop the click sounds because they're if
they're not being raised in Zulu culture
and they're encouraged to make the M
sound because they're being raised in
the English culture and so on so
basically this shows the yellow plots
with error bars show that babies babble
they do not obey this law then they
don't obey this law in adolescents
because they're getting very redundant
so instead of being very diverse making
all sorts of sounds they turn to
redundant making the sounds of early
English and then they wind up where you
see on the far right with this law well
the the blue R is a recordings of two
baby bottlenose dolphins that were born
at marine world and if you look at the
the yellow underneath it is the blue
line so the to superimpose in other
words we recorded baby Bono's dolphins
and they were babbling their whistle
language they're making random noises
that landed exactly on the Zipf
distribution that we gotten for babies
babbling so in others we could show
mathematically that the baby dolphins
we're babbling there whistles and they
don't get into the mama mama-mama thing
too much they don't go down as deep as
the yellow line but they wind up with
minus one slope just like human so we
caught the babies we can show
mathematically that baby dolphins babble
their whistle language until they learn
it and then that when they learn it it
obeys its law so bottlenose dolphins
adult bottlenose dolphins obeys IFS law
and this was the first time a nonhuman
was shown to obey this law and since
then there have been several other
species that obey this law humans
bottlenose dolphins not squirrel monkeys
and not ground squirrels so and this is
a syntax diagram which shows that
dolphins also have second-order entropy
in other words they have conditional
probabilities between their signals so
they have a kind of syntax or grammar I
don't know what term to use besides
saying quote syntax and grammar because
animal linguistics is a young field that
will no doubt have its own nomenclature
sometime soon but for now I'll just call
it conditional probabilities between
signals which makes sense because it's
important they communicate to each other
and have error recovery that exceeds the
ambient noise in their environment and
this is one way to do it this is the
mathematics of it just want to show you
there's honest-to-goodness mathematics
behind information theory and I'll just
keep it at that except the P the log
tube means that the units are in bits
the unit the bit unit was introduced by
Claude Shannon for information theory
and so when you if you know have heard
what a bit is then you're talking the
language of information theory and the P
means the probability of occurrence of a
signal so basically first order
information entropy is you add up all
the signals probability of each signal
and the log base two of the signal and
what that means is that will how often
will the signal occurred
how much information is in that signal
you add all those up and you get a
number for the Shannon information
entropy and the word entropy is similar
to that used in thermodynamics in
thermodynamics you have a gas and you
open up a container and the gas can be
in more states with a larger container
so the entropy increases and we know
that from our you know if we leave our
rooms alone and come back into our room
and things are scattered all over the
place
then you know that's just simply entropy
in thermodynamic entropy
well information entropy is how many
possibilities you have so the
information entropy of Chinese
characters which are thousands exceeds
that of English which we have basically
27 units if you include space but it
doesn't mean we can't say the same thing
in English that we say in Chinese it
means though that English has to start
in to the higher order entropy
relationships before Chinese does okay
humpback whales may have the most
complex acoustics in the ocean they
certainly have more signalling than
human language in the average human
language and they also had what might be
called a global internet millions of
years before humans did they basically
the ones we studied are in southeast
Alaska and that's where they make social
calls and feeding calls when they go to
Hawaii that's romantic they're supposed
to mate and they sing songs so there's
definitely a difference between Alaskan
vocalizations and Hawaiian vocalizations
as there would be between an average
conversation human and an average human
song there's all sorts of indications
about how intelligent they are and
anyway here's what some of them sound
like again
[Applause]
now there was a piece of song in there
you did hear oh ye like that and that
was a piece of song but mostly it
doesn't sound like the songs usually
think of humpback whales is making
because these are these are chatting
these are social calls and discussions
of things like bubble nets and how to
fish so we know how back whales also
make Nets of bubbles to catch herring in
and usually if they want to not if they
don't make bubble nests they just shovel
like krill which are a kind of shrimp
into their mouths with their long
flippers but they've developed a skill
in southeast Alaska and I'm not sure
where else in the world where they build
nets of bubbles and they basically
shovel the they chase the the herring
into these nets and then they come up
with their mouths open and eat them I'll
show you a net in a minute but I want to
show you a I want you to listen to what
might be considered an argument in how
back well sometimes the bubble nets fail
and there's this kind of chatter
argument which if I wanted to answer
percent eyes at anthropocentric eyes
this observation it would be that
they're arguing I was there where were
you see what you think
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so it doesn't sound very romantic does
it so here's an example of bubble nets
on the right is an illustration and from
the air the diameter of those spiraling
bubble nets are about a hundred feet and
they catch herring in them and we've
tried reproducing a bubble net in
miniature and it's very difficult the
idea we just don't have the
technological intuition that they have
whether it's Boyle's law which has to do
with gas bubbles and expanding or
Brunelli principle buoyancy and you just
have to have a lot of technical
knowledge to catch fish in a net of
bubbles listen to this
[Applause]
so we heard that one day and it was the
tempo and frequency range of human and I
thought of trying to make talk to each
other underwater when we are kids and
that's what it sounded like it was a
basically an attempt by the humpback
whales I think to communicate in human
that's of course an over interpretation
maybe but it sure sounded like they were
attempting to make human-like sounds
what you just heard was a humpback sound
so what we want is their language not
ours so the first thing was to say
everybody quit talking so much in the
boat but I think that was an attempt of
a nonhuman to communicate in human to us
not that far from SETI when you think
about it okay and here is an example of
a bubble net coming up with us nearby
taking pictures and this is a feeding
call again by a humpback that we
nicknamed miles after Miles Davis a
trumpeter see what you think
if I were herring I would run from that
but it turns out that the humpbacks make
this sound that is in resonance with the
body of the herring so they don't have
much choice at all they're gonna be
scared into the net bye-bye the
humpbacks and they've been doing this
for millions of years we think here's an
example of a bubble net movie
[Applause]
killer
[Applause]
then we have to take pictures of their
tail tips because that's how you
identify individual humpback whales
[Applause]
there we go that's the ID so just
looking at them from there you go well
they're pretty alien aren't they they
grow up on the same planet around the
same star and they have a global
communication system and there is
socially networked their social network
is complex and they use tools and in
every other way they're very intelligent
we can't put it down to their non
intelligence that we haven't
communicated with them I would put it
down to our kind of anthropocentric
viewpoint of our own communication
system but we're working on it so here's
an example of an intelligence filter the
outline Russian letters English letters
Arabic letters Russian phonemes dolphin
whistles humpback whales social and
feeding calls all land within what we
call the intelligence filter if we got
an extraterrestrial signal and it landed
in this box that would be news that
would be really interesting
unfortunately squirrel monkey calls
ground squirrel calls and so on as well
as how back whale and birdsong fall
outside the intelligence filter but
elephant rumbles fall in it so we're
working with different increasing
species to see who lands in the
intelligence filter so the results are
we can distinguish astrophysics from
intelligent extraterrestrial signal we
we know that other socially complex
species obey the rules of information
theory even an extraterrestrial system
would
have to obey the rules of information
theory in order for knowledge transfer
to take place that's important point you
they cannot get around what information
theory measures they would have to their
communication system would have to obey
information theory so we're beginning to
apply this to any kind of message
signaling that is obtained from the
Allen telescope array eventually the
terrestrial applications would be to be
able to quantify different species
ability to make syntax out of their
communication system and we think they'd
maximize this because of the error
recovery benefits if we get an
extraterrestrial signal some
anthropologists have said that human
complexity human cultural complexity led
to human vocal complexity so that if we
measure the communication complexity of
an extraterrestrial signal we might also
be able to obtain at the same time be
obtaining their social complexity so
it's kind of a neat idea to measure
their social complexity mathematically
of an extraterrestrial civilization so
should we look up at the sky and say are
we alone no I think we should well
that's all very romantic and stuff but
we should be paying attention to the
non-human communication system somewhere
on earth we have millions to to learn
from thank you very much are we alone no
here's goodbye by the way we think it
means goodbye and humpback Thank You
Lawrence that was a fantastic tour I
think you know certainly one of the
larger shocks here is the breadth of
communication coming across everything
from plants to the number of animal
species as well as that the complexity
of those will also be getting joined by
Stewart Brand and Kevin Kelly who are
sorting some of the questions coming in
from the audience or at least
is and they'll they'll be joining us as
well briefly but I'll start this off I'm
curious as to you know I think many of
us know that SETI search for
extraterrestrial intelligence as an
agency has been doing this kind of work
for a long time but I'm curious who else
is doing steady research around the
world and what other governments or
other privately funded organizations and
are any of them doing animal
communications research like yours
well there are SETI people in France and
in Russia and Australia and other places
around the world but they're probably
almost entirely radio astronomy people
and there is also an animal
communications community that's doing
research since we introduced this idea
of using information theory it's been
adopted by people studying gorillas and
Rowell snakes and bats and and you know
all sorts of critters that signal each
other but as far as I know the
colleagues I mentioned I are the only
ones that are mixing and matching SETI
with animal communications and what was
your background team cool and what was
your background that got you combining
astrophysics and in this research well I
was always interested in my astronomy
career in extraterrestrial life and my
dad gave me a map of the solar system
when I was six and there's stars in the
background and he said the stars are
other people's sons what I remember the
shock of that and it never quite left me
it's amazing I was always interested in
life in the universe so I naturally
migrated to SETI but it seemed to me
that when the astrobiology program
started and everybody's using Mars as a
proxy for asari Antarctica as a proxy
for Mars
that we could use non-human
communication as a proxy for an
extraterrestrial signal so I got in
touch with some of the animal
communications people working
specifically with dolphins Diana Reiss
Laurie Marino and eventually Brendan
McGowan who's now my colleague and went
up to see the dolphins at marine world
and there's this vague notion that
there's something helpful from dolphins
that could be applied to SETI and that
but it had been in the original study
meaning that Frank Drake organized there
was a dolphin person but nobody
connected it and then one day I had this
idea of plotting to see if dolphins
obeyed zips law and Brenda had sent me a
paper and I took I think was column
three from Table four or something like
that and I plotted it and it gave a
minus one slope and so I went had a cup
of tea and did it again and it was still
minus one when I got back so I called
her and ever since then that was we took
off there's one of those moments where
you take off in a new direction that was
the first combination I think of animal
communications and SETI cool we have a
couple questions coming in from the
internet and then we'll be pulling in
Stuart soon after that but we had
several people as well as Kevin Kelly
Rick Corrado Mancuso from Facebook
stream as well as Kevin Kelly asking
about different species and if they
follow Zipz law and I think you might
have shown this as I graphed towards the
end but do you know just to confirm that
do the bees follow
Zipz law the cotton and wasp
communication and the humpbacks are they
all on zips law or where do they fit
humpback whales yes bees I haven't done
yet really but I have an approach based
on polar coordinates and the bees seem
to be able to find honey farther than
the resolution of the waggle dance so
they may be using syntax that would be
an amazing thing to find out that bees
have a second-order entropy the cotton
plant does not the cotton plant
definitely does not have
second-order entropy so bless their
hearts you know it's very simple
straightforward not much opportunity for
error recovery and that may be why the
cotton plant puts 2.4 bits when if there
are only two predators it would only
need one bit to distinguish between them
but it puts in 2.4 bits of information
when it transmits to that wasp and so
that may be making up for it in
redundancy instead of syntax mistake and
we'll pull Stewart in for his question
after this one but Wilson Tang from the
Facebook feed
has anyone ever applied zip slaw or some
of these tools to analyze social media
to understand fake news from real know
news and I think the other side of this
question is how about machine generated
communications that that we're now
seeing like machine generated stories
fantastic idea
zip slaw I've been asked to apply it to
undeciphered Manus manuscripts working
on a paper with Brenda right now
applying it to Rango Rango which is the
only undeciphered well it's the only
written language of Polynesia the
Voynich manuscript but and also too I
hate to mention this but I'll go ahead
and stick my neck out but somebody asked
me to apply it to speaking in tongues in
a church to see if it really was a
language so yeah it'll apply to all of
the above and I love the idea of
applying it to machine code I haven't
done that yet and you know any of these
kind of applications drop me a line if I
can do it without too much trouble I'm
happy to you know to take a look to see
if it indicates a language or not a lot
of things are claimed to be language
that may not turn out to be and you know
the fact that we have a diversity in the
animal community where some are and some
aren't and the ones we follow zip slaw
do show syntax syntax so yeah great
question
I would I haven't done those yet but I'd
be up for it
cool all right well we'll bring in
Stuart brand president and founder of
long now and post of this series before
me soon welcome Stuart
greetings Lawrence this is terrific
you're finding such wonderful stuff
where you've looked so far I'm curious
what questions you're asking yourself
that will lead you in what direction is
next
well I with regard to humpback whales
we're looking into I'm looking into the
difference in information between
humpback whales social calls and
humpback whale song and comparing it
with a difference between human speech
and human song because humpback whales
have claimed we say they're singing but
do they do the same thing we do to
produce a song versus speech so that's
one paper I'm working on another one has
to do with bottlenose dolphins where I
was giving some lectures in the Canary
Islands and observing they're using
their you know they have a lot of large
telescopes in the Canaries and good
weather and there's a little island next
to Tenerife a that's called Gamera and
on Gamera they have a whistle language
developed 2,000 years now by the
shepherds and it's deep valleys and all
and they whistled to each other so I
went there and recorded a bunch of
gomeran silbo whistles and we use them
to classify those whistles we use the
same technique that we use to classify
dolphin whistles so people that say
you're comparing oranges and apples
well now we're comparing oranges and
oranges because we're comparing a human
whistle language with a dolphin whistle
anguish so that's kind of an example of
some of the things that we're doing to
try and get a broader application in the
animal communications community but also
it's in the SETI community this is
information theory is handy stuff so
those are some things are working on
we're also using information theory to
further quantify some
of the communication systems that may be
happening with humpback whales for
example when they jump out of the water
and breach it's been recently suggested
that that's a communication system so
we're looking we're applying information
theory to breeches and to see if it's a
drumming kind of communication so yeah
it's if I see you're smiling and I have
to smile inside myself because the
applications don't seem to be very
limited and if and when we ever get a
extraterrestrial signal we're gonna know
something do the whales use different
kinds of signaling when they're doing
the long distance calls versus the whale
so right next to yes that's interesting
they they tone it down when they're
closer to each other it turns out that
whales including humpback whales can
make something like 180 DB vocalization
which is like jet engine
so yeah they they know we're there and
don't kill us with you know shouting and
the prytt the percussive signals that
they would do from breaching would be at
a really low frequency that would travel
further like more like an elephant
rumbling with its it's by stomping its
foot right well very similar except that
it's a broadband signal and what's
interesting about it being broadband is
that the ocean is really good there's
certain aspects of the ocean salinity
and so on but turns out magnesium
sulfate in particular an boric acid are
great absorbers of sound and so given
that you can know the conditions of the
ocean the higher frequencies will be
absorbed selectively with distance so
that the distant humpback whale
receiving the breach from one of the
others would know by the absorption of
the higher frequencies how far exactly
that humpback whale is so yeah they're
they're able to signal each other and
get exact distance information to each
other just from that first breach the
does do these breaches
is there any way slaps or breaches would
show a tempo that would be indicative of
a zip flaw type relationship stay tuned
that's a famous SETI saying we we always
say stay tuned and that's when we have
to say this time just one more question
you said you have been studying human
speech versus humans song and are you
getting structurally different readings
from that well it's a little early still
to tell but we know that human octave
music I haven't done Eastern music yet
or sitar or anything like that but human
Octavia's ik does obey this law quite
well and has the same entropic structure
out to maybe third order entropy the
words however this is the song these are
the notes the words especially of some
of the modern songs
I'm afraid do not have very high order
entropy you know I mean I I'm a great
fan of Casey in the Sunshine Band but
that's the way I like it uh-huh uh-huh
it's not exactly zip slaw stuff nice all
right well thanks for joining us Jarrett
well we'll move on nice to meet you my
pleasure we'll move on we actually have
some questions coming in from Laura
welter who's a linguist on our team has
worked on the Rosetta project and some
of the our efforts to write things that
go have gone into space like on the
original rosetta mission she does a lot
it's just several questions really about
meaning versus the knowledge that it is
communication are there parts of these
tools that could be used to identify the
meaning of this of these signals as well
as just that they're intelligent yes
that's the big question right now is the
transition into meaning and I think the
safe way to approach meaning is if you
can start to analyze do information
theoretic analysis of communication
systems where you know what the purpose
of the communication is then you can
begin to back out and quantify meaning
one example that ye o Wilson point
doubt was that an aunt comes from a food
source talks to another aunt talks to
another aunt chemically and and they
also make little sounds and then the
other aunt makes it to the food source
within a certain Gaussian distribution
well you can actually quantify the from
that result because you knew what the
purpose of the communication was you can
quantify in bits how much minimum
information the first aunt had to have
communicated to the second aunt an order
from the second dad to do that well at
at the purpose of the communication
which is finding the food source and
with in case of humpback whales we know
that the purpose of the bubble net is to
catch fish and so on so I think if we
want to get it meaning one of the ways
we can approach it first is to start to
analyze communications that we know the
purpose of the communication and we
start to quantify how many minimum bits
had to have been transmitted for the
animal that was communicated with to
have it be able to achieve amount of
success at the purpose from that
communication so I think that's the safe
way and we might we might have some
assumptions of what someone's or what
another species is trying to communicate
if they are sending a high powered
signal through space we might think that
some of those signals might say things
like hello right yeah I have some of
that and the difficulty is that there's
mostly very complicated communication
systems have a lot of symbolism in them
eyed bees for example don't they talk
about flowers and there are no flowers
in the hive so they're talking about
something isn't present so you try and
do a direct correlation with actions oh
every time they say dolphin they you
know they wave their hands or something
or and it's like what I'm doing is
talking about something that isn't
present and so I'm using symbolic
communication and I know that's a catch
word in linguistics you have to be
careful with but the bottom line is that
a one-to-one correlation with you now
actions and vocalizations does not take
place if you're talking about something
isn't there so that's another difficulty
with trying to jump straight to well you
can do simple things like there's a
thunk call that dolphins make and the
mothers make and that means the baby
come here right now and there's a whip
call that humpback whales make and you
make it back and they'll approach you so
it may mean welcome or hello or
something so but it's only the simplest
communications you're going to get that
way if they're communicating something
more complex it's probably symbolic hmm
all right well thank you and we have
we're gonna be wrapping up questions
fairly soon here but I wanted to invite
on Kevin Kelley one of our other
founding board members and the person
who usually sorts these questions so
welcome Kevin Lawrence how are you good
how's it going sorry I talked too long I
really enjoyed your presentation and it
sparked all kinds of ideas you were
mentioning idea of using whale breaching
as perhaps trying to interpret it as a
form of communication I would suggest
that studying human dance might be a
good first step to try and understand
the structure of physical communication
and so that's a neat idea
human dances because should you should
be able to get some kind of grammar or
vocabulary from that the the one the
other question I had was he was about
one of the things that's pretty clear is
that intelligence is not just binary but
it's also probably more than a single
dimension in right now you have
basically just one dimension you have
the H whatever that is have you done
much work in trying to understand what
the different dimensions of animal
intelligence are because it's probably a
pretty high dimensional space you mean
variables in action variables in in
communication types like for example
ants communicate chemically and audio li
and they even use drumming on just some
leaves start but it's very clear from
the initial work in artificial
intelligence that there are men
varieties and different kinds of
elements that make up what we think of
as intelligence that it's just not a
single dimension and your work so far
with different like zips laws and and
the entropy suggest that there are
probably multiple dimensions and I'm
wondering like if you could kind of like
instead of just saying well there's a
ladder of intelligence in animals and
they climb up maybe it's three
dimensional or four dimensional and you
know whales have a particular maybe they
have a higher memory or or another kind
might have an ability to process
deductively perhaps certain
intelligences are better at solving some
kind of efficiency and so I'm just
wondering in this world of studying
animal intelligence whether there's any
sense of mapping a taxonomy that's more
than just a single dimension well like
we have looked at other non audio but
audio is of course the one we can
quantify the best and you know the basic
idea of looking at audio signals first
this is a new field it's the idea of
different and I think there's supposed
to be twelve different kinds of
intelligences we will not get
encephalization quotient from aliens you
know the one that applies to SETI is the
communication intelligence using
information complexity as a proxy for
for information intelligence so if we
get an extraterrestrial signal I think
that's the first kind of intelligence
we'll get unless they land or whatever
they do and I and so it's a bit of a we
recognize there are different kinds of
intelligence and different ways of
expressing it and we hope not to be
prejudiced hopefully but guided by the
mathematics but we're just starting this
is so I got some templeton money and so
you know this is really a budding field
it's just starting off I know one thing
was you have an assumption that you're
looking for patterns of language
and I was wondering if you could imagine
ETS that had intelligence with that
language or whether that's sort of
something we just have to assume right
now because we have that well that's a
yeah symbolic language like it was I
guess it was the Babylonians had
cuneiform and the ancient Egyptians had
our Olympics and the Phoenicians got
tired of translating between the two
they said let's just use the sounds and
so we have a field named after them
phonetics and that's kind of like did
that they were the first to invent an
alphabet and the only one independently
to invent an alphabet except maybe the
Maya but so yeah we have when you mix
and match huge fields like linguistics
and information theory with non-human
communication systems it's yeah so I can
just beg that we're starting out and
playing it safe but we're aware I have
one last question I'll let me turn it
back to the to the audience but I kind
of envisioned for a long while the
search for Internet intelligence and
yeah I don't have any suggestions about
how you would structure that so that you
kind of felt like you were on the boat
like you're going to filter out the comm
the common human to human communication
and you're looking for another level of
intelligence that's arising at a
planetary scale
do you have any suggestions or hints
about how you would do the search for
Internet intelligence well you write the
if you could get rid of the linguistic
you could look at just searches I guess
and treat those as signalling units
that's a question I've never thought of
how to think about and happy being
correspondence with you but yeah the
machine intelligence in general but
internet intelligence would be
interesting to see if it obeys this law
I thought we could raise some money by
watching politicians give speeches and
then we could have a little zip slaw
indicator and see if it was babbling
after they finished all the news media
would pick it up all right well thanks a
lot let's be in touch about that I would
think about it sorry I had myself the
will wrap up with these last couple
questions here but a deal con from the
YouTube feed ass is said he's still
crunching legacy data F now that machine
learning is more developed so some of
these old efforts like SETI at home or
some of the past listening feeds has re
is some of the newer techniques being
applied to that legacy data you know
that's the interesting question I have
to ask dan wit Wertheimer about that I
don't know if they started to apply more
AI or neural net techniques they still
running SETI at home but we started out
by supplying the data at SETI Institute
and then Berkeley basically took over
and cooked away and so that's a question
I can't answer but I will ask him and I
think one of the amazing things about
your research that I found is that it's
it's fundamentally it's separating the
question or not it is this communication
from is this even intelligent
communication to a certain extent
there's obviously there's intelligence
factor here that gets it further closer
to zip slaw but it also separates it
from the question of what transmission
techniques a civilization might use how
are we listening for things that might
give us some of this information well
you know as I mentioned narrowband
carrier wave is what you know 1 Hertz
wide is where said he does their search
and if they get a carrier wave they
don't look at the content of the message
they just look at the carrier of the
message so if that's narrowband and they
can say there's a technology out there
assuming astrophysics can't make at 1
Hertz wideband carrier wave so you can
look at the radio information and if
interstellar electrons are broadening
the carrier wave as it goes across the
galaxy we would miss those civilization
so looking at the content I think it's
important addition to the radio search
the other another way of doing SETI is
optical SETI where it turns out that we
can get millisecond pulsars but as far
as we know nature doesn't make
nanosecond pulsars they would fly apart
so even if you make them as strange
quarks but that's another story but it's
called
optical SETI and it looks for nanosecond
pulses as indications of technology but
once again we could look at the content
of those pulses and the rate of those
pulses because they'd be carrying
information and there's all sorts of
other things we can do like I'll give
another example is Mars has a natural
microwave laser in its atmosphere pumped
by the Sun and so at 10 microns Mars if
you surround Mars with mirrors you could
send interstellar optical or infrared
SETI over interstellar distances and be
free because the Mart atmosphere of Mars
is you know powered by the Sun and it
does this amazing all the time so
there's an example of a SETI thing we
may do someday
and finally I'm writing a paper now on
what I call quantum SETI
and it's basically pointing out that
well for example a quantum computer has
not really been built there are tests of
it and I would say Google's come the
closest to demonstrating a quantum
computer so far with NASA but what if
they're teleporting information then a
very advanced civilization would use
quantum computer to teleport information
and so what if we receive the first SETI
signal in a quantum computer instead of
a radio telescope so I'm I'm not
advocating we give up radio searches I'm
just saying there there's a diversity of
SETI approaches that are all being
thought of and I'm working on a paper in
particular about using quantum effects
to tell if there are observers and other
galaxies so stay tuned
it's all very budding this is where
there were the
new kid on the block the average solar
type star around our neighborhood is
much older than us so we've been having
radio for a couple hundred years and you
know so I expect anything we run into
that intelligence wise is going to be
very much more advanced and I would
suspect that what we're doing now will
be naive but you have to start somewhere
and tape well I want to thank you very
much for this the last thing I just
wanted to ask is how is how is Teddy
faring during this time are you all able
to continue your research is there parts
that are being limited or not well the
early part the middle part of Drake
Equation is suffering the most because
that involves searches for biology and
like the URI Miller experiment and
things like that where you're trying to
generate early earth-like conditions to
see if biology can occur and also
meteoritic 'men analysis things like
that so basically getting in wet labs
has not been possible so and the
astronomers getting to the observatory
is difficult so they're having a hard
time to and we had to cancel our alaska
whale season this year but that just
means write papers we got lots of data
so i'll down up and down the Drake
Equation
everybody's on hold but they're getting
their papers written and catching up and
now's a good time to ask him hard
questions nice excellent well I want to
thank you so much for this and we hope
to see all of you at the next talk thank
you so much
[Music]